I got a call from the LA Lakers from Rob
palinka you know on and a half itself in
Jeanie buss and they just asked me know
how can the Lakers meet make a
meaningful impact during this movement
and it kind of drew me back you know me
because I kind of feel like some and
like I said this is just my thinking and
I love everybody
I feel like some white people feel like
what do I need to do to let let everyone
know I'm down with the movement what can
I do to help or what could I do that you
know so when I when I when I sat back
and told them like man that's a loaded
question I'm about to hop on a zoom but
let me smoke and give me till the end of
day and I'll shoot you back some some
ideas so I hit it back first and
foremost and I was just like this can't
be a PR stunt this can't be a let me
throw a band-aid over a knife now I'm
like hey [ __ ] they know it's
going you know like really like with the
Lakers being where the Lakers are you
can set a president you know you can
start a fund you can you can you know
you can let go of the LAPD you know
that's what a lot of people there's
there's certain things you can do you
can mentor a black child with no parents
whatever I mean but whatever you do just
like make it serious because you can you
know I mean the Lakers are one of the
greatest diner and chives in the history
of sports so you set a president not
only for the NBA but for other sports
franchises to really try to get involved
like I think it's crazy that you haven't
really heard any of it and if I owner
speak out on this
you haven't really heard too many of the
NCAA coaches football or basketball
speak up on this and you think who
drives revenue and both those sports
young black men you know what I mean so
you really haven't had how these these
obviously you know these NFL owners it's
this is mostly this not they're
obviously their main business but what
makes their business boom is black play
killer Mike said but is this is this
fair man I think and I think a lot of
them you know like Drew Brees came out
and he thought he was fighting the good
fight and he [ __ ] he flubbed one word
but he thought he was saying the right
thing and then he gets attacked I'm out
probably the best guy in the NFL who
goes back to New Orleans who neither
yeah more so than anyone yeah so I think
a lot of it and you're speaking out are
scarier because it goes you're racist
you think oh yeah to me I want you to
speak from the heart when Drew Brees in
this I've always been a fan of Drew
Brees
no but always been a fan when he
initially came out I thought it was very
tone-deaf in bad timing and I was I said
some [ __ ] that I that I said just being
me what you fire off onto it ah yeah and
then he then he came back and kind of
gave a half-assed apology and I thought
that was just because he would their
people in the front of house saying [ __ ]
drew brees you know but when he snapped
Jenkin right but someone but when he sat
down and really gave a heartfelt apology
to me you have to under like because his
track record has been incredible for
giving back to the community and doing
this yeah being a great guy but you know
as the black community we want people to
understand our point of view and we want
people to change so if so if drew brees
thought initially that the need was
messed up which he thought it was but
then at some point he ended up me and
bla bla his goes back and forth but we
want change we want people to be open to
change and understand it just with your
own eyes just see what's going on
okay killer Mike said something I
thought was really interesting I love
that [ __ ] he's at least I went down
that rabbit hole cuz I've been very
until he made that speech I don't know I
feel like I learned so much every time I
hear him talk correct and I'm listening
to him and and he said he they said the
same thing what can we do is you know
white people in sileo's I mean I'd love
to see some people take there are a lot
of kids that that don't have parents
that need parenting that need help and
and and mentor that child figure out a
way now we're all so [ __ ] busy
everybody's so goddamn busy but if you
really wanted to get down to brass tacks
there are kids out there that can use a
big brother big system their kids they
could really use guidance their kids he
could could use that to me it's about
education mom so my family did the big
sister program this isn't gonna shine a
good light on it we got a girl this
girl's a real man she came to the house
and I was like oh hell no
uses you they're friendlies you should
work on beat
I'll just say thank you easy for them
yeah yeah but way to go no shoes 13 well
yeah I think when white people ask like
what can you do I think the biggest
thing that was just you know obviously
educating yourself but calling out
racism you know I mean to embarrassment
people getting fired all that kind of
stuff has to continue happen like the
black worried Matt that that I worry
that when you find somebody who makes a
mistake in isn't racist you know you
find somebody who's who says something
insensitive did you buy Drew Brees
shouldn't of losses I don't want them
because that what happens is that's a
reaction all of a sudden people go under
seizure why people are scared but but
but you have to understand I mean it's
your you can educate yourself about
everything right here yeah two minutes a
day right one minute a day you know you
look so so to me there's no excuse for
an ignorant comment at this point
anymore you know what I mean we've
always given passes they don't live our
lives they don't understand this that's
it's okay it's not it's finally for the
first time ever it's not okay to be
ignorant or oblivious to our struggles
but there are arguments right so there
are there are scholarly arguments that
may seem insensitive but let me give you
an example when Ben Shapiro who's a
conservative will say I don't think it's
about race I things about culture that's
a point of view and and and and people
might find the fence you see a lot of
white people go you hate you don't know
what the you don't know what people go
through but but bench peer will mount a
very strong argument a woman on as an on
rate he's an Orthodox Jew he's suffered
is you know whatever the case is I we
have to have we have to we have to allow
room in the public debate to have these
debates and have these conversations
that will be uncomfortable because
that's how you move things only being
people outside understand like the only
way with grow that grew you never grow
when you're comfortable you never you
never grow in your comfort and I think
positive I think so I really do at 2020
first of all has been a [ __ ] the worst
year ever it has it's the worst episode
of all time I mean you know start you
know starting with Kobe it's been a
domino effect of not bad things but
horrible thing Kobe passed away when
January 26 my birthday you know what I
mean huh
so it's been that it's been this
pandemic and then it's
you know the biggest virus we've had
that we haven't actually found a cure
for has been race so it's been one thing
in effort or another so it's just been
such a hard thing to swallow but I
really feel like you know they say the
Sun that the Sun wouldn't feel so good
if it was for the rain like it's been
pouring on the world you know
particularly the United States so I
really feel like something good has come
out of this it's gonna come out of this
but one thing you can say you know if
you whether you want to point out the
looting the riding the protest whatever
it's been all races you know and we're
all together on Sunday a hundred
thousand people have you seen laughs oh
that annoys me a little bit and
embarrasses me a little bit its first of
all white celebrities just can't wait to
[ __ ] virtue signal just I'm not even
working until every black like all right
dude we get it you're not realizing but
then but then white people I feel like
in the protests are trying to help do
it's almost like it's [ __ ] showing
that show how we just we just want the
support you know in an open minded
understanding you know I mean just have
an open mind and just understand before
like I said before I've said if you it's
been okay before to not understand where
we're coming from but now it's not you
know and you have to edit we even as a
bit of the black community have to but
there's so much we have to learn there's
so much we have to do moving forward
like I said for the first time in 400
years they hear us right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]